the world is celebrating the birth of
Britain's newest royal baby bells
ringing today at Westminster Abbey in
London to mark the princes birth he is
the third child of Prince William and
his wife Kate and the fifth in line to
the British throne Roxana Saberi is at
Kensington Palace in London where the
newborn is resting with his family this
morning Roxanna good morning to you good
morning while the baby whose name has
yet to be revealed was spending his
first night here at the palace the
papers were busy printing headlines like
this little prince perfect and his first
royal wave the new Prince probably won't
remember his first public engagement as
a member of the royal family but he'll
need to get used to this kind of
attention earlier the day he and Kate
had their first visitors William went
home big sister Princess Charlotte
showed the new arrival how it's done she
has reason to smile thanks to a recent
change in the law she's the first royal
daughter to keep her place ahead of a
younger brother as heir to the throne
[Music]
Kate didn't keep royal fans waiting long
she was admitted to the private
maternity wing of Saint Mary's Hospital
early in the morning gave birth just
after 11:00 a.m. and came out
camera-ready less than seven hours later
heading home but royal correspondent Roy
Anika says Parenthood in the palace
isn't picture-perfect she has a you know
plenty of staff at the palace there's a
nanny in for George and Charlotte
there's a housekeeper there are Palace
staff named shafting the food but at the
end of the day she is just a mother with
a newborn baby and that's a handful for
anyone even with stuff there's no word
yet and what the couple will call the
new Prince so the name game continues
I'll go for James Edward I'm going with
Phillip I think Arthur Arthur is also
the bookies favorite and it's a middle
name of the newborns father and
grandfather Prince Charles who said in a
statement this morning he's so pleased
to have another grandchild but he
doesn't know how he's going to keep up
with all of them John Roxanna before you
go have you heard why she was able to
leave the hospital so quickly and look
so good that's a great question right a
lot of us were wondering that well she
had a great team of you know a makeup
artist hairstylist and medical experts
at the hospital and were also told she's
got medical staff here on hand to you
and another team here to help her in
case she has any more trouble yeah if
you said okay baby done want to go home
all right thanks I remember thinking I
want to stay here a couple more days
exactly before I go home it was
fantastic where they will the baby in
and then will the baby out that's right
Congrats everybody wasn't watching